[Music]
you know I think often we think about
social classes just being about our bank
accounts we don't sort of think about
how is class cultural truly cultural in
terms of differences in values and norms
that are socialized in different groups
for good reasons and and tightness
looseness it doesn't just differentiate
nations and states it also
differentiates social class with the
same exact logic we went out and we've
been surveying people from the working
class and people from the middle and
upper classes and what's fascinating
when we ask people about rules just tell
us five words that when you think of
four rules we see that the working class
sees rules very positively rules in the
working class are important they're
important for helping people to slide
into hard living as sociologists would
call it to poverty to the dregs of
poverty rules are helpful if you're
going to be going into occupations where
there's a lot of danger where there's
less discretion the middle class and
upper class they saw rules more
negatively they saw it as goody
two-shoes when you're following the
rules for the working class rules are
important for survival for the middle
class there's a safety net so you can
actually afford to be rule-breaking in
this context and what's fascinating is
we measure the zip codes of people
coming into our lab and then we track
the neighborhood's they live in and and
for sure the working class live in much
more threatening environments when it
comes to crime unemployment they report
being subject to many more threats
what's remarkable is this starts very
early we wanted to see how early can we
see these two these difference is
developing and we started to see this
even as early as three years three years
old and the what we did was we brought
three-year-olds into the lab
working-class and middle-class kids you
can't exactly ask them about rules okay
but what we did was we borrowed a
technique from the Max Planck Institute
where we had them interacting with a
puppet his name was max the puppet and
they got to know him and they enjoyed
playing with him and max the puppet
suddenly after a little while became max
the norm violator
he said valuating all the rules of the
game and announcing that he's actually
playing the game correctly and we simply
wanted to know how did the kids react is
there a difference of reaction by age
three and there sure was the middle
class in general we're much more likely
to laugh and kind of let it go and the
working-class kids wanted max the puppet
to stop
they told him to stop they told him what
was wrong and you know parents but age
three are already socializing their kids
to enable to help them fit into the kind
of threatening or non-threatening
environment they're going to be working
in so it's really important to see that
these differences arise for reason and
they arise early so the rise of Donald
Trump has been such an enigma to so many
people is it an ideology is it a
personality in fact Donald Trump is semi
he's a very good cross-cultural
psychologist he understands the role of
fear and threat in mobilizing people to
want more tightness in to want
autocratic leaders and we've seen this
in our data the people that were
interested in voting for Trump felt very
threatened and they felt the country was
too loose and this is not just a Trump
phenomenon it's all over the world when
we measure support for Lipan in France
we have the same exact data that showed
that people who feel threatened want
stronger rules and leaders to help them
coordinate to survive these leaders tap
into a very important evolutionary type
of instinct that when there's threat and
when there's disorder we want strong
rulers to help us in those contexts and
one thing that really predicts whether
groups are tight or loose is the amount
of threat that they face and threat can
be from a variety of sources it could be
from Mother Nature it could be natural
disasters or famine or it could be
population density it could also be
man-made it could be in the number of
invasions that you've had over the last
couple of centuries and so when there's
threat there's the need for strong rules
to coordinate to survive and so actually
tightness looseness has a real really
important logic a hidden logic that
helps us understand why certain groups
become tight or loose loose groups
whether they're nations or States or
organizations they face less threat so
they can afford to be more permissive
groups tend to evolve to be calibrated
to the degree of threat that they have
when you have exaggerated threats it
means that we're sacrificing Liberty for
security and context when we don't
really need to do that the problem here
is that we have to separate objective
from subjective threat it's true that a
lot of working class does objectively
feel very threatened in this country and
we need as a loose culture to reach out
and work to
to help them deal with the threats that
are happening from globalization but
it's also the case that we ders like
Trump and others use threat and target
people who are threatened in order to
gain popularity
[Music]